welcome to this video the second part of
the yeah the road to the world
championship series presenting great
games by the two participants your
champion Vichy honored and Challenger
Martinez Carleton and turn this turn is
some yeah form four thousand game so
let's let's start and then going to
start with the rather old game
don't panic garden standards from 2004
so back then it was only 13 years old
not even a grandmaster at the time just
an international master rated 2480 84
and this was played in vikon's in the
traditional venue for this tournament
this had that has seen quite a number of
names over the years who opens
tournament back then the chorus
tournament no it's called Tata Steel
tournament but the cars then didn't play
in the first group of course the the a
group but in the C group which means the
third third best group very often this
tournament while being very strong as
some it's a mixture of some some -
juniors and some accomplished GM's but
um thousand well being one of the lower
rated lower rated players in this field
won this tournament with a big score of
10.5 points out of 13 scoring lots of
wins and then the game I'm showing he's
playing against the second place in the
tournament that sure Grandmaster I'm not
quite sure if he was a GM at the time
probably not against at the time else
was also rated about 2500 he later got
much stronger even being higher rated
than 2600
so a pretty pretty strong permanent
buyer by the standards of the time um
yeah and this was really hardens
breakthrough tournament he was certainly
no one before that for for inside us but
winning the C group with such a big
score was a huge deal
actually I'm to put my own perspective
into this so it was quite funny at the
time to recognize that I actually had
played cards and a couple of years ago
on the ICC because he was playing on the
ICC from a very early age under the
handle of Magnus and it had in the notes
I will always remember that something
like this hello from Norway Magnus
Carlsen ten years old and at the time of
course you thought it was a joke because
it was playing really really well and I
also lost games I mean I'm pretty sure I
want one one of those games but I lost
many games and you cannot really believe
it's a ten-year-old I always thought it
was a joke and then like three or four
years later you see that this name
wasn't some invention but it was a real
ten-year-old that that beat you ok so we
have a cup come here let's go to the
game and it's the classic online with
Bishop f5 let's see
it's form this is the most testing
approach to the classical threatening
the bishop and gaining space on the
Kings side here with age five this
exchange yeah this is some very well
known if the classical variation with
four there should be a five is played
you will almost always get this position
we should have form yeah here why it has
a principle choice between Bishop d2 and
Bishop f4 quite often it's transposes on
Bishop f4 now has placed Knight f6 there
are alternatives but I can also
Karia this Czech trying to provoke the
move c3 which might not be a move that
white wants to play if he intends to
castles long a black can also play Queen
a5 with cellular ideas and after Bishop
d2 returning but this means that the
queen is committed to c7 or a matter of
six is perfectly alright I'm just
mentioning the alternatives long castle
who should be seven and ninety four yeah
this is all very normal to be one
protected the a to pawn and now
Catholics short so this is the yeah I
think you can still call it the modern
interpretation of the classical where
black castles short and not castles long
um you can go back to the to the 70s or
even earlier when black almost
exclusively was playing in this way like
him let's let's put the shiny bottoms
this kind of this kind of setup with
long castles and now they all all go
from short castle try to later get
counter play with c5 and also get cannot
to play against the king
the reason why this was young thought to
be a bit suspicious for for a long time
is that white has has already made push
d4 d5 to open up the G fall but it seems
that this is not the end of the world
okay check console now exchanged on f6
and centralize the knight very natural
approach what played rook e8 and Queenie
to Lissa looks like a prophylactic rules
getting the Queen out of the the rooks
way certainly it is it is a prophylactic
movement in a way but
also a little trap connected with this
move and in this game on the DL sports
right right into this trap the best
moves for black here are Queen b6 or
Knight to d5
for example let's put it on the board 95
and Bishop c1 and it was attacked and
then prepare a play place e5 black
should have sufficient counter play here
it's a rather standard position for this
this line but has played this
immediately and in fact this move leads
to big trouble for black maybe if you
want to treat this as an exercise I'm
not expecting you to to calculate the
upcoming complications to the end this
would be a huge accomplishment but just
to maybe you can can find the idea along
at the quiet for a couple of seconds all
right so the key attacking in fear
played by colonists Knight g6 and this
is very nice
just hopping into the slightly weakened
square by age six the square was
weakened and yeah what is the point of
this we see what happens if black
captures because this is what what
disappearance played here the only
alternative would be to eight not giving
up an exchange and after the this move
which is yeah not ideal obviously but
like shouldn't lose exactly why it would
take take on c5 and now it's not so easy
to recover this pond because um you
always have this the situation on the
default that if black guy takes on d1
can't grab
this Bishop d6 and you lose the whole
look here so it's difficult to recover
the pawn black can hold on though and
try to fight for example long after this
maybe route to d7 let's say rook d7 g7
should be through yet
you can try to to round up this pawn
maybe move the rook 97 wide is clearly
better but it's still not an immediate
loss however okay I'll just just grab
this grab this man and now we see a very
very forceful attacker coming check
Queen e6 check and the point is okay of
course that the bishop is hanging so
what should like do went here the point
is after Queen e7 there's ninety five
and there's an attack on both pieces so
this isn't ideal
it's like would come look f7 it's easy
just winning this rock and what else is
there could go here check then white
would just take him this kind of line is
really devastating also the simple
captures also began so King edge rate is
the most testing and what what now as we
saw this is not not really great and so
what modern is played is very strong
just captured on g6 and this obviously
introduces a big threat in the position
this is Bishop takes h6 opening up the H
file so like really has no alternative
to 298 what you played also now is
heaviness
hanging for example if like place this
year it takes and now 95 there's a h6
and it's made next smooth it's very very
dangerous
so 98 is the move to play but okay
what's next
it's really am a bit of a steamroller at
this game why it just takes on h6
smashing open the H file tanks and
here's the next sacrifice just busting
open the king position yeah black needs
to take this is checkmate made in one so
Knight takes Queen e7 this is all quite
easy to calculate even from 96 I think
this is easy but what you need to do is
they just thought that it is really
winning because black now has a
defensive move it's the simple threat
but it can be can be defended but not f7
and here in this position you need to
see before and if you win with you 20
play 96 that here white has a decisive
continuation it is obviously very
dangerous but what exactly is the win
for example if Chang white starts with
Luke h1 check which looks completely
normal after King g7 on where's the
sorry can g8 where's where's the win
it's not not sleazy let's say move like
Queen f6 unite h6 and it's not not an
immediate made Posner I found a very
convincing continuation and this is G
takes f7 just thinking and now it's some
multiple threats yes this this part for
the look and also look h1 of course so
this is now absolutely indefensible let
them have a look for example if black
plays this trying to use the Queen to
defend there's Queen e5 check check
under around here I didn't analyze this
in detail but this looks like yeah this
looks like it should be an easy win
threatening this with mate I'm waiting I
made it to moose and I guess there's
there's no defense this is also made
checkmate or this one
check check yeah why does this up how
many points four pawns yeah four pawns
and so rather rather straightforward
plan yeah zip could played the King King
g7 here and now group d3 is the decider
the good old looked left yeah no defense
King if the Queen helps my eyes to help
it will just like taking that now d5 is
strong the problem is that the rooks are
simply
tied together you cannot take here you
cannot take here and you cannot miss the
ropes so why this has enough time to to
push the pawns and at the end get to the
king
you played a look to d6 check here we go
check check and Queen e5 from here it's
a first mate nicely very nicely against
now now - sorry
very cute finish after this King e7 is a
bit tougher I mean number of moves check
this is very very easy win
like check this white grabs everything
it will made and a couple of moves but
he played the rook F 6 here and allowed
checkmate Queen d7 mate being played on
the board and this is a very nice
version of them April 8th bullet I'm not
sure about the pronunciation mate where
the king is
it's wrapped of two squares by rooks or
could could also be other pieces like
Knights or a knight would take that
would take yeah it's looks nothing and
it's a very nice mate this is covering
the backyard of the King so to say the
ropes here taking away the the flight
squares so I'm very nice not too
difficult to actually very nice
attacking game and I chose this game
because it's it's a nice nice easy game
but also because it marks a Cardinals
breakthrough performance and people
really got got good we have that there's
really big talent coming you don't win
this this White Sea tournament with 10.5
points and when you're 13 years old
without being an extraordinary talent
and in 19
in 2004 this year cars also became he
became a grandmaster and the tournaments
right after this bike tournament he he
Scott I think GM knows and in every
tournament and really quickly got got
close to him to a to world-class level
yeah I hope you enjoyed this game and
I'll be back tomorrow with another game
of the two players I think this would be
an honest game again thanks for watching
I hope you enjoyed it till tomorrow
bye